bonjour madame aranha ce fait bonjour
alors vous êtes juge de la citoyenneté
oui on vous reçoit aujourd'hui pour
parler justement de la semaine de la
citoyenneté
oui exactement d'abord on aimerait
savoir un peu votre pack au parcours
parce que bon j'ai appris que vous étiez
journal eut que vous avez été
journaliste et particulièrement à radio
canada international donc expliquer nous
un peu votre parcours
oui mais je suis journaliste j'ai étudié
en journalisme au liban j'ai travaillé
en journalisme au liban j'ai immigré au
canada en 2003 et depuis mon arrivée
j'ai appliqué pour travailler ici à
radio canada international et j'ai été
accepté j'ai travaillé à la section
arabe de radio canada international
pendant dix ans je dirais plutôt pendant
neuf ans est un enjeu les j'ai travaillé
avec la première chaîne et la télévision
de radio-canada donc de journalistes
juge de la citoyenneté cc c'est toute
une affaire
exactement vous amener à être juge
je cherchais un travail je cherchais un
travail avec le gouvernement fédéral et
par pur hasard vous regardez sur le site
web du gouvernement pour les pour les
pour les pour les jeunes pour les jobs
et je suis tombé sur cette annonce
deux juges de la citoyenneté je me suis
dit engagé aucun espoir
je n'ai pas étudié en droit je peux pas
je peux pas faire présenter ma
candidature pour ce poste mais j'ai lu
que c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir des
études en droit pour présenter pour ce
poste spécialement alors je me suis dit
je vais rien perdre et j'ai envoyé ma
candidature je reçois la première
réponse si - après six mois
comme quoi j'ai été retenu mon cv a été
retenue pour passer un examen écrit j'ai
passé un examen écrit ensuite un examen
oral une entrevue orale et au bout de
d'un an et demi j'ai eu la réponse
finale quand même un appel du ministère
pour m'annoncer que j'ai été choisi pour
être juge de la citoyenneté par me au
total la commission de la citoyenneté à
dix jugent à travers le canada compte
dix jugent à travers le canada dont deux
au québec
moi je suis une des deux et justement
quand on est juste de la citoyenneté si
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des études en
droit c'est quoi les facultés les
caisses qu'il faut avoir comme bon au
moment où j'ai lu ce que je devais avoir
pour représenter pour ce poste il y
avait soit bon c'est toujours un atout
d'avoir un diplôme en droit avoir étudié
en droit ou quelque chose de similaire
avec mon expérience comme journaliste au
liban ici au canada avec tous tout ce
qu'on a fait comme sujets concernant les
immigrants concernant l'immigration la
citoyenneté et on a vraiment travaillé
sur ce thème pendant des années et des
années à radio-canada
j'ai déjà mon expérience dans ce dans ce
domaine le journaliste le journaliste en
général à un bon jugement parce que être
responsable d'une nouvelle bien un
reportage ou bien d'une information qui
va transmettre à un nombre illimité de
personnes ça c'est une grande
responsabilité et l'école de radio
canada fait de très très bons élèves à
avoir de télé très bon jugement
il doit être impartial on l'est il doit
savoir faire des entrevues parce qu'un
juge doit faire des audiences et doit
savoir comment retirer l'information du
client qui est devant lui on le
journaliste est un peu comme ça aussi
quand il fait une entrevue et il cherche
son scoop on a tous les atouts que les
qualités que vous aviez
professionnellement vous ont finalement
permis absolument d'avoir être nommées
juges et concrètement un juge de la
citoyenneté
ça fait quoi oui à juge de la
citoyenneté ils étudient ou bien ils
jugent sur des cas bien limitée des cas
compliqué qu'on lui réfère
pour faire pour rédiger des décisions
pour faire ses décisions vous savez
quand on présente une demande de
citoyenneté ça peut aller dans les avec
les demandes de routine où il n'ya pas
de problème le candidat répond à toutes
les exigences dont qui a pas de problème
j'étais sûr c'est exactement
lorsqu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
quelque chose qui cloche
comme par exemple un problème de
crédibilité
un manque d'information
à ce moment là l'agent de la citoyenneté
revise la demande et essayer d'avoir
plus d'informations et de documents qui
prouvent que ce candidat a résidé
effectivement au canada ou bien ils
répondent aux exigences de la loi
si l'officier ou bien l'agent de la
citoyenneté n'est pas convaincu à ce
moment-là ce dossier va chez le juge
le juge fait des audiences avec le
client et puis s il décide après s'il
est convaincu de donner la citoyenneté à
cette personne ou non mais parce qu'on
parle de d'octroyer la citoyenneté et
quand même exactement quelque chose de
petit l'or non c'est celui délivré à vis
à la personne donc il faut être sûr que
la personne et ce n'est pas n'importe
quel cette citoyenneté celle citoyenneté
canadienne
il se déroule en ce moment
laissez moi juste ajouter deux petites
choses parce que ce n'est pas tout en ce
qui concerne le rôle du juge de la
citoyenneté il préside aussi les
cérémonies de citoyenneté effectivement
bien sûr trois exactement et il est
responsable de faire la promotion de la
citoyenneté à travers des activités à
travers des entrevues comme à ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui à travers différentes
différentes occasions donc justement on
en revient à cette semaine la sésamie
capter qui fait partie de votre travail
finalement du 8 au 14 octobre
oui la semaine de la citoyenneté qui
consiste à rappeler aux citoyens
oui c'est pour sensibiliser les citoyens
canadiens des d'immigrants ou des
canadiens qui sont nés ici le sang les
sensibilise
envers la citoyenneté leur a plaidé de
leurs de leurs droits de leur
responsabilité est de penser un peu à
comment on peut conserver ce statut très
respectable de notre citoyenneté
canadienne
parce que vous savez c'est la
responsabilité de chacun de nous c'est
la responsabilité de chaque citoyen moi
en tant qu immigrants dont je suis quand
je suis arrivé au pays
la table était mise tout était prêt les
lois sont là les l'infrastructure d'un
pays parfait et ou quasi parfait la
perfection n'existe pas mais tout est là
et mon rôle a moins c'est de participer
a vraiment laissé cette table bien
propre bien prête à ceux qui vont venir
après et au à mes enfants aux enfants de
mes enfants
et c'est comme ça notre rôle c'est
vraiment de conserver et de protéger
notre citoyenneté et protéger cette
bonne réputation kona oui bonne
réputation le canada est considéré dans
le monde comme un pays ayant une très
bonne réputation donc les absolument
c'est quelque chose qui est important de
promouvoir
qu'est ce que la citoyenneté canadienne
a de plus que je sais pas moi la
citoyenneté américaine
ça dépend de la du passeport et lui
demande ce qu'est ce que ça a de plus
c'est vraiment ça revient à chaque
personne
je vais vous poser la question à vous
comment vous sentez-vous comme citoyen
canadien mais c'est ça c'est la fierté
que vous ressentez au fond de vous c'est
ce qui fait la différence entre notre
citoyenneté est une autre nous sommes
tenus d'être laid le peuple le plus
gentil au monde
nous sommes connus de dormir la nuit
dans nos maisons sans barre et les
portes nous sommes connus avec le taux
de
criminalité le moins élevé peut-être en
amérique on est connue d'être très
serviable on est connue d'être très
gentil on est que j'ai dit gentil ça
revient ça revient les connues méconnues
qu'on respecte notre environnement et on
le respecte pas juste pour nous mais
pour la terre pas seulement pour notre
pays on le fait pas juste pour nous on
respecte notre patrimoine
on respecte l'autre on respecte l'autre
inconditionnellement
donc c'est des valeurs aussi beaucoup
c'est surtout les valeurs c'est surtout
les valeurs canadiennes qui font la
différence entre être canadien ou
quelque chose d'autre
sans vraiment dire que les autres sont
pas bons tout le monde est bon mais moi
en tant que canadienne
je suis fière d'être canadienne laissez
moi vous dire une chose vous savez je
préside plusieurs plusieurs cérémonies
de citoyenneté par semaine et à chaque
fois je rencontre quelqu'un qui vient me
voir à la fin de la cérémonie qui
accompagne quelqu'un qui qui obtient sa
ce citoyenneté cette journée là qui
vient me voir il me dit moi je suis
canadien
je suis né ici j'ai jamais ressenti
cette fierté d'être canadiens comme au
moment de la cérémonie de la citoyenneté
c'est c'est vraiment un moment
exceptionnel savoir que nous faisons
partie de ce peuple de ce pays de cette
patrie c'est vraiment quelque chose
c'est un événement parce que de toute
façon même dans votre expérience jeu
probablement dû passer cette cérémonie
vous en tant que citoyen y bien sûr et
je m'en rappelle de maintenant fournir
la citoyenneté à des à des nouveaux
citoyens
ça vous fait quoi c'est c'est magnifique
j'ai cru que c'était vraiment le le
sentiment que je vais avoir juste aux
premières cérémonies que je vais
présider mais ça dure et ça dure et ça
dure et ça se renouvelle à chaque fois
que je préside une cérémonie
là la réaction des gens l'émotion des
gens devant moi est très contagieuse je
ne peux pas ne pas être content tu peux
pas ne pas être heureuse je peux pas ne
pas être touché par cet événement il ya
des gens il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pleurent au moment où ils reçoivent leur
citoyenneté
c'est un moment très touchant
pour vous dire aussi c'est parce que
dans la dans le processus de routine de
l'immigration de la citoyenneté
peut-être ce n'est pas un processus
extrêmement long ça peut durer peut-être
six ans ou bien 5 6 7 ans en tout pour
obtenir la citoyenneté
si on compte du moment où on a présenté
notre demande pour immigrer au canada
ensuite elle réside et la période qu'il
faut pour obtenir notre citoyenneté
l'étude du dossier jusqu'au au moment de
la cérémonie
ça peut durer six ans peut-être mais il
ya des gens qui ont attendu 12 13
c'est parce que il arrive en tant que
réfugié pour obtenir leur statut légal
ça leur prend du temps pour obtenir leur
statut de résident permanent ça ça leur
prend encore du temps pour présenter la
citoyenneté c'est encore du temps c'est
une vie douze ans c'est long douze ans
c'est pour cela qu'ils arrivent au
moment où ils ont cette citoyenneté ans
clément et sont comme vous ne pouvez pas
savoir qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
nous c'est très touchant et dans cette
semaine de citoyenneté est ce que
justement vous oui il y aura des
cérémonies spéciales à travers le canada
72 peut être en total il y aura trois
cérémonies qui y seront qui auront lieu
sur le top de certains de certains tours
il y aura une cérémonie qui aura lieu
sur le top de la tour cn à toronto
c'est une cérémonie spéciale où six
personnes seulement vont avoir leur
citoyenneté
il va y avoir une autre cérémonie à
vancouver aussi sur le top d'une tour et
une cérémonie à montréal le 12 octobre
sur le top de la tour du stade olympique
que je vais présider demain que moi mais
tout un panorama et tout le monde est
invité 1
c'est une nation m oui c'est ouvert au
public toutes les cérémonies de
citoyenneté c'est des occasions ouverte
au public
donc on ne manquera pas ça la semaine de
la citoyenneté du 8 au 14 merci madame
rania ce faire on le rappelle vous êtes
juge de la citoyenneté
merci à vous merci beaucoup